con origen en el subcontinente indio su
presencia en la península ibérica está
documentada desde hace más de seis
siglos pero en españa el pueblo gitano
es todavía víctima de prejuicios son una
comunidad distinta es decir muy
hermética y al no haber mezcla siempre
se las ha visto como cierto reparo
nadie quería vivir cerca si ibas un poco
sucio
o con el pelo despeinado de chiapas de
tu plátano de las 750.000 personas
gitanas españolas la mitad vive bajo el
umbral de la pobreza una situación de
precariedad y de racismo denunciada por
la onu
son tratados como menos que nada no
tienen acceso a ningún servicio social
decente la policía no entra en las zonas
donde viven y básicamente los gobiernos
los han dado por una causa perdida
nos desplazamos a sevilla al polígono
sur el barrio más pobre de españa como
pedro más de 15 mil gitanos han crecido
aquí está
una prueba más de cómo cuando se diseña
el barrio quieren que polígono sur se
quede ahí la gente polígono sur no se
mezclan esta sería la este
tenemos la barrera en el oeste y tenemos
la barrera en el norte de tal manera que
era la creación de un gueto puro y duro'
un gueto de donde es difícil salir por
ejemplo según la fundación secretariado
gitano sólo el 2 por ciento de los
gitanos llega a la universidad
[Música]
también como
cómo
porque te tratan como inferior
los demás alumnos ten cuidado ten
cuidado que viene para ir a gitana o
esto es que son muchos comentarios que
no sabría decirte enumerar te en los
comentarios y yo me he dado cuenta de
que hay mucho racismo y muchísimo
racismo cuando es salido de estudiar de
mi barrio qué pasa cómo estamos
ser gitano y vivir en el polígono sur
implica doble discriminación denuncian
sus vecinos dando el trabajo a él y no a
mí y lo llamo los dos mismos capacitados
que no luchar contra la exclusión
profesional de las personas gitanas es
el combate al que se fuera ha dedicado
su vida
a mi hermana de familia de vendedores
ambulantes se fueron es una de las
primeras mujeres gitanas abogadas de
españa
hoy continúan frecuentando los
mercadillos para defender los derechos
de los suyos en los 600 años de
persecuciones sistemáticas que ha tenido
el pueblo gitano donde se nos prohibió
absolutamente todas nuestras señas de
identidad
todos nuestros puestos de trabajo la
venta ambulante ha sido la única vía
donde hemos podido sobrevivir no hay
igualdad para nada cada vez nos exigen
más cosas llega un momento en que las
personas de
que dependen de esto no saben cómo
después sobrevivir si fuera denuncia que
los vendedores ambulantes son tratados
como ciudadanos de segunda a pesar de
que la última ley anti gitana en españa
fue abolida en 1978 desde entonces
tienen sobre el papel los mismos
derechos que todas las españolas
marcos decidió también dedicarse al
derecho para combatir el anticatalanismo
ahora hacemos el juicio vale
considera que los gitanos todavía sufren
discriminación frente a la ley
cuando los gitanos son los que acusan
que han sufrido discriminación y se
amparan en el código para los nuevos
tipos penales
pues parece ser que eso no es en la
práctica no está teniendo éxito no se
denuncian esas conductas en córdoba a
unos pasos del tribunal se reúne la
asociación acá mira que ayuda a las
mujeres gitanas a combatir el racismo su
prioridad es que las jóvenes conozcan
sus derechos y oportunidades no hacerlas
dependiente sino intentar un poco
dignificada a nuestra familia a través
de la formación a través de bueno pues
informando las sobre empleo etcétera sin
embargo lamentan que esta ayuda no
siempre sea bien recibida por los
sectores más conservadores
cuando le he dicho para no ser mi hija
tiene 20 años lo primero que te dice tu
hija no se ha casado todavía yo creo que
también hay que trabajar con los padres
defender su identidad a la vez que
luchan contra el racismo continúa en el
orden del día del pueblo gitano siglos
después de su llegada a europa